am freitag besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
das europäische hand entschärfer zentrum
in der wiener vega payer weyprecht
kaserne
dabei handelt es sich um ein projekt der
europäischen union eu experten tools zur
kampfmittel abwehrt dazu gehört das
aufspüren von sprengstoffen mit hunden
sowie die entschärfung mit robotern wenn
alle technischen hilfsmittel aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht zum einsatz
kommen können
dann ist die zeit der hand entschärfer
gekommen bundesheeres kommen dann zum
einsatz
wie wir gesehen haben wir einen sicheren
abtransport beziehungsweise eine
kontrollierte sprengung sowie wissen
zuvor gesehen haben nicht durchgeführt
werden kann das europäische hand
entschärfer zentrum ist international
besetzt mit experten aus tschechien
deutschland finnland italien schweden
und österreich und bleibt bis 20 24 und
der österreichischen leitung